okay you got a fact matter that yes okay
good you made it in a second now when
you hear the word exponential there are
a few different options for this but
what what's the next word that you
expect to come in the phrase growth I
think is the right exponential growth
and that just means something's where I
really fast right well there's a
specific kind of exponential growth that
there is AI comes from this okay now
exponential growth doesn't just mean
grow through that's very very fast okay
it means a particular kind of growth let
me put it to this way right um x squared
it grows fast right but X cubed R is
faster and you know X to the 300 grows
faster okay
these all grow very fast but they're all
the same kind of growth we call them
polynomial growth none of them no matter
how ridiculous this number gets none of
them are as fast as exponential growth
because doing something different okay
the idea behind exponential growth is a
population right the larger population
gets the faster it can grow right now
make sense like rabbits you know the
more that there are of them right the
more quickly they can reproduce it's not
just all they'll keep growing faster
it's by their very nature the more
rabbits there are the faster they can
make new families and that's exactly the
same thing is happening with money the
more money you have the more interest
you can make which means more money you
have right so in other words what
distinguishes the e cigarettes even it's
as fast is that this is going to get
ever faster and it's proportional to how
big something is so the bigger it gets
its just gonna go crazy okay now think
about this with me just think about a
particular rat suppose I just have a
dollar right I don't know if you guys
realize this but if you have five
dollars right and you have some interest
rates on the other time that five
dollars is going to earn exactly the
same amount of interest as a dollar he a
dollar here dollar he dollar here
here okay do you get fired backing out
over the dollar of them and just by
putting them in a pile of five dollars
they don't magically throw more interest
you go ahead and hand you check out the
numbers exactly that's it okay so
therefore I'm just going to consider the
case of one dollar because every dollar
in my bank account they're all the same
they're all going to behave exactly the
same way
it's got what's them doing the same
thing okay now let's suppose there's a
very very generous bank account which
gives you a hundred percent interest
okay
now this sounds very generous doesn't it
but why do you think in terms of the
real world actually it's not that
unusual think about a population right
if you've got like rabbits they
literally can double right and actually
doesn't take them a year to do it
okay so this is not that unusual right
so let's consider one year a hundred
percent interest okay so this is number
one okay what will happen to my dollar
what will it become you'll become two
dollars and the reason why is because if
we one plus the rate hundred percent
which is just 1 ^ 1 so you get two okay
now as you know though at least if
you're dealing with money right they
don't wait for the end of the year to
pay your extra dollar okay
actually they're calculating interest
constantly and the more they calculate
it your money you get right so let's do
a bit of an experiment number two
suppose instead of waiting for a whole
year they do it say twice a year
semester level okay now here's what I'm
gonna have to do I'm still getting a
hundred percent interest per annum right
so the father is not going to be this
great how must I adjust this formula
there are two compounding periods but
here's something / - what's going to
divide by 2 so the rate instead of
getting a hundred percent at the end
I'll get 50 percent and then I'll get
another 50 or seven so I get yes that
make sense so what's that equal to
that's yeah one huh is going to be 2.25
right
nine and a four to a quarter so this is
better this is good right well why just
do it once every semester why don't you
do it every month what formula should I
write 1 plus 1 over 12 to the 12 okay
calculators tell me what you get two
dollars sixty three sixty six one
channel 61 okay now this is interesting
look when I doubled I got an extra 25
cents it's not bad sex with 10% plus
right for Rita here I've gotten more
frequent but I'm still gaining more but
actually thanks good even more than this
right they'll do it every day for you
right okay it's number four yeah they
won't pay it every day but they'll
calculate every day I tend to pay
monthly
so what equation should I write one plus
one on 365 and every day they're going
to go and calculate the interest she's
tiny tiny time to point now give me some
more decimal places okay all right now
what's going on right I would say from
monthly to daily you've increased your
rate of compounding dramatically but all
you've gained is like a piddly ten cents
all right well just for the sake of it
maybe you think there's something wrong
with their computers forget it every day
we have favor fast computers now let's
do it every minute okay another fine so
let's go one plus one on every day 365
how many hours 24 how many minutes 60
whatever that is okay 365 24 60
someone's calculator guess what
spoilers it's 2.71828 blah blah blah
blah wait 71 days what happened now
here's the thing right I didn't even get
a whole set out of it right I suppose
you can round up what happened well you
know what like all of these these are
just arbitrary okay what mathematicians
do is they say forget all of this for
days months hours you and your feeble
units of measurement they just say well
what happens here you just say
infinitives
right now in math we call this a limit
because of course you can't actually do
this infinities not number it's just an
idea
all right but you can take some numbers
you're pretty close you can take like
million something whatever large number
you like I do it really angry you did a
trillion and I'll tell you right now
you're gonna get $1 okay this number
just like pie I didn't say oh it better
be a certain number I better get there
right it comes from a structure that
exists in nature namely how things grow
when they grow in relation to their own
size
or if you like how things decay when
they decay with relation to their own
size half-lives those kinds of things
radioactive decay temperatures that come
down the hottest something is the faster
it loses temperature okay this is this
is the number of proportionality or
proportional growth or proportional
decay and that's why it's so important
right because that's why it appears in
your cat is because it's a it's a number
that exists in reality just like pi does